[Applaudissements]
être vieux
ce n'est pas si grave la vie pour la
plupart des gens c'est comme les
asperges au début l'enfance s'étendre
joyeux insouciant l'adolescence est
toujours bon
les premiers amours les espoirs les
découvertes et puis ça se durcit la vie
professionnelle des responsabilités
c'est toujours des gus table puis il
arrive un moment où ça devient si dur à
mr plein de fibres que l'on essaie
heureux d'arriver ou moi j'ai dû avaler
ma vie d'aspect rj à l'envers le début
était coriace combatifs les l'école les
parents sévère et puis la guerre
les masques à gaz les sirènes d'alert et
puis l'occupation nazie l'étoile jaune
ma famille se cachera en dordogne sous
une fausse identité
déjà meilleur l'apprentissage très tôt
dès 14 ans de mon métier d'imprimeur
puis le maquis la résistance de plus en
plus tendres la libération l'amour les
enfants la vie de mon entreprise
la création les voyages aujourd'hui je
suis dans cette partie
croquante et délicieuse libres heureux
j'ai créé délire et j'ai je ne redoute
qu'une chose c'est d'arriver à la fin de
mon asperges
comme disait woody allen
je n'ai pas peur de la mort mais quand
elle se présentera
j'aimerais autant ne pas être là les
opinons asperges 6 à merci dur c'est de
l'occupation à 15 ans je rentre dans le
maquis de corrèze et je maintiens tulle
agent de liaison
en réalité je porte les plis d'un mac l
autre à vélo avec un cartable sur le dos
pour avoir l'air d'un gamin qui va à
l'école un jour de 1943 sur un pont des
soldats allemands aidés par des
miliciens contrôler les papiers les
miliciens c'était ses collabos
extrémistes chargé d'arrêter les
résistants les juifs les gitans et les
maquisards et de le remettre à la
gestapo
un milicien m'arrête me fait descendre
de mon vélo et me demandent mes papiers
ils étaient faux et le message que je
portais était particulièrement
compromettants
j'étais sur le point de lui montrer mes
papiers
quand un soldat allemand à l'autre bout
du pont l'appel en lui demande de venir
immédiatement mirare le milicien préfet
c'est de partir depuis cet instant je me
suis dit que rien de vraiment grave ne
pouvait m'arriver
je ne suis pas encore blasé jeu 89 ans
et demi à partir de 80 en fait les deux
mises anniversaire comme les enfants on
ne sait jamais parfois au cours de ma
vie je me suis demandé c'est quoi de
dieu à quoi pense-t-on on fait quoi on
aime quoi on entend la mort avec un
mélange de patience et de peur ou bien
on en repousse l'idée en essayant de
vivre encore intensément en regardant
autour de soi en participant en tentant
de comprendre ce qui se passe dans le
monde
j'ai donc choisi la deuxième solution et
je m'en sors en écrivant des lieux
la route vers le bonheur n'existe pas
d'ailleurs même si elle existait elle
serait tellement encombrées qu'elle ne
sera pas praticable en revanche est en
empruntant des petits sentiers secrets
que l'on découvre en regardant autour de
soi des petits bonheurs délicieux il m'a
fais rarement de penser à la mort le
c'est un mot de toute façon que je
n'aime pas ce tableau sinistre fin de
vie ne semble plus adapté à ce que je
ressens il faut bien que ça finisse un
jour cette belle aventure
par contre la disparition de mes amis
est difficile à accepter
je me sens parfois comme dans une forêt
qui aurait subi un ouragan et vous serez
le seul arbre encore debout
ce que je redoute c'est le fauteuil
relax dans lequel on s'assoupit dans un
demi sommeil doucereux et cotonneux mais
pour l'instant j'en suis pas là souvent
le demande mais comment tu fais pour
avoir encore la frite après trente
années
je ne suis pas un gourou capable de
donner des leçons de vie joyeuse ce que
je peux c'est vous faire partager un peu
de mon énorme caisse de souvenirs
mélange d'allégresse de mélancolie et
d'une certaine forme de béatitude
il ya des années de ça des années des
années
une amie me disais ce qui m'agace le
plus sans toi c'est que tu es toujours
bea
soixante dix ans après je suis toujours
béat devant les inventions les
innovations les films les livres la
musique le design
oui je suis baird quand je consulte ma
tablette pour tout savoir sur blaise
pascal ou pour trouver une nouvelle
machine à laver et qu'elle clignote les
rangs tendu et en quelques sons en
quelques secondes me dit tout sur ce
cher blaise en me proposant les 100
derniers modèles de machines à laver
autrefois si tu voulais informer
rapidement sur penseurs ou sur le
dernier modèle est trop ménager tu
devais abonnés un service téléphonique
payant tu composes svp 11 et le sur le
cadran de ton téléphone et tu posait la
question une hôtesse elle consultait ses
fiches et te rappeler svp 11-11
répondait à environ 5000 questions par
jour
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de 3 milliards
de recherches sur google par jour
soit près de 40000 par seconde
oui super sub et à quand je prends le
tunnel sous la manche dont j'ai eu la
chance d'assister à la réunion des deux
tronçons pendant sa construction
je suis béat quand on apporte quand on
m'opère d'un simple rayons au lieu de me
charcuter comme autrefois
c'est le genre de chose qui me donne de
l'espoir et me fait croire que l'homme
peut être extraordinaire et la femme
aussi bien sûr en commençant par la
mienne et je vais vous raconter notre
première rencontre
elle était plutôt surprenante c'était
l'époque des surprises-parties des
chenaux du swing on a mené ces 45 tours
et sa bouteille de whisky
j'invite une fille à danser je lui
demande son nom
elle me répond les veilles c'est drôle
moi c'est claude weil a bruissé marron
et une djellaba
c'est ma soeur c'est micheline veille
enfin ça s'appelle aussi micheline
veille
mais ne me dites pas que votre père
s'appelle robert mais si mon père
s'appelle robert aussi
mais il est mort mais le mien aussi
c'est fou où habitez vous dans dix
septième moi aussi et vous avez 19 ans
moi aussi
nous sommes repartis ensemble nous avons
descendu l'avenue niel il faisait sombre
et très froid les a mis sa main dans la
poche de manteau et voilà soixante dix
ans que nous sommes ensemble nous avions
des métiers totalement différent je
dirigeais une entreprise de plv de
marketing au point de vente
lise elle était chirurgien dentiste en
plus de son cabinet elle avait créé un
service de soins dentaires gratuits dans
un hôpital parisien
c'était avant la cmu ensuite à la fonte
d'une association avec quelques
confrères et partait dans des régions
très éloignées où aucun dentiste
s'aventurer sait soigner des gens qui
risquait parfois de mourir de nutrition
parce que lord ans était en mauvais état
et qu'ils devraient plus s'alimenter il
formait des habitants aux premiers soins
elle a aussi travaillé dans les andes à
plus de 4000 mètres d'altitude ou au
nicaragua en pleine guerre pour repérer
dans ces régions sans électricité liz
avait créé une valise spéciale avec un
ingénieur la partie supérieure
renfermait un panneau solaire et
l'intérieur une unité complète de soins
dentaires
la valise de lise comme l'appelait à ce
moment là est un outil maintenant
couramment utilisés partout dans le
monde
pour cet engagement et pour bien
d'autres elle a reçu la légion d'honneur
des mains de bernard kouchner
quand nous nous retrouvions nous avions
tant de choses à me raconter et c'est
peut-être un des secrets de la vitalité
d'un autre couple m'a béatitude n'aura
pas empêché d'être souvent révoltés
indignées bouleversé par l'injustice et
le fanatisme 10 et moi nous avons milité
pendant 40 ans amnistie internationale
pour défendre les droits humains et
c'est en se battant pour cette cause
commune que nous avons rencontré des
gens merveilleux et qui sont devenus des
amis proches à madagascar j'ai participé
à la construction d'une école et d'un
village d'accueil de 100 maisons et une
école et qui progresse encore grâce à
son créateur daniel dupuis malgré les
immenses difficultés rencontrées dans ce
pays un jour un ami que j'admirais
beaucoup m'a dit il ne faut pas mourir
avant d'avoir écrit un livre il est mort
sans avoir écrit aucun moi j'ai suivi
son conseil
j'en ai déjà écrit 14 mais il faut que
je me dépêche
après les événements de charlie hebdo du
magasin casher et du bataclan
j'étais abasourdi abattu je ressentais
heureux moi inquiétudes et découragement
par défi par révolte
j'ai voulu écrire un livre joyeux et
insouciants essayer de redonner pour un
instant le sourire à mes proches et aux
inconnus qui liront ce livre j'écris 0
tristesse illustré par claire maupin à
qui j'ai confié les dessins de cette
conférence voilà vous l'aurez compris
être vieux ce n'est pas si grave
je n'ai pas de recette de vieillesse
joyeuse à vous donner
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'à 30 ans à
30 ans non à 89 ans et demi j'ai encore
soif de découverte d'aimer et de me
goinfrer des asperges
merci
oui
je suis